they chose a rugby stadium to swear in
the New South African president
[Music]
that way tens of thousands could attend
and celebrate the inauguration of 66
year old Cyril Ramaphosa he's promised
to fix an administration wracked by
scandal and the public bore witness as
he promised to follow the law he'll need
help to turn things around for the most
developed economy in Africa is also the
most unequal 27% are unemployed and the
president's party the ANC is beset by
corruption allegations the people
deserve better he said of the very
institutions of our democracy eroded and
resources squandered the challenges that
our country face are huge and they are
real but they are not insurmountable
they can be solved and I extend here to
say that they are going to be solved
there was one notable absentee the
former President Jacob Zuma has spent
much of the past week in court fighting
16 counts of fraud racketeering and
money laundering he told his supporters
he was too busy trying to stay out of
jail the new leader is offering South
Africa something of a fresh start and it
may be the last chance for the ANC the
party of Nelson Mandela has truly turned
in our country a brighter day is rising
upon South Africa and a brighter day is
rising upon our beloved
continent Africa thank you very much Val
opposer says South Africa's problems are
huge and they're his problems now yet
many in this expectant nation think he
can solve them John Sparkes Sky News